and we're learning about new covid
related travel restrictions coming in
overnight that now start days from now
cases at home are surging as they are
also surging in london with a new strain
of the virus good morning
merry christmas welcome to this edition
of america's newsroom i'm leland
julie if we didn't know it was christmas
all we need to do is look at your shirt
or your tie what are you kidding we're
both like a christmas tree this morning
i'm julie banderas leland merry
christmas to you merry christmas to all
of you at home joining us this morning
a rainy morning here in new york uh
sandra smith is off
so the cdc says beginning on monday
anyone
coming from the uk will be required to
have a negative covid test
before boarding and if airline travelers
refuse
they can be denied entry into the u.s
this comes as a new and
more contagious strain of the virus
spreads in britain
and beyond it is yet more transmissible
and it appears to have mutated further
than the new variant that's been
discovered in the uk
this is what happened in the spring
it is deja vu they lost
track of the virus
aisha hosni is live in new york city the
governor and mayor have called for this
and now they have it good morning aisha
good morning to you leland and julie
merry christmas to you yeah this comes
on the heels of a lot of criticism from
new york governor andrew cuomo who's
been blasting the trump administration
really all week long
saying that they did not take quick
enough action
once this virus was known over the
weekend he wanted
nationwide travel restrictions and now
he's got them the government will now
require
travelers from the u.k to show that they
have had
a negative 19 test within three days of
departure
in a statement the cdc says airlines
must confirm the negative test result
for all passengers
before they board and if a passenger
chooses not to take a test
the airline must deny boarding to the
passenger the cdc says uk travel has
already
been down by about 90 percent because of
travel restrictions in place
since march but there are still six
flights expected to come in today from
london heathrow
and landing in the new york area areas
major airports here and they have the
potential guys
to carry thousands of travelers that is
why new york governor andrew cuomo
mandated a similar testing requirement
earlier this week
delta british airways virgin atlantic
all three of those are requiring
passengers from england to
show that they've had a negative covet
test before they get on a plane headed
to new york
united now joins them next week for
flights arriving to new jersey's
newark airport so far though guys no
confirmed cases of this uk strain
anywhere in the u.s not here in new york
just yet but
testing just got underway at least here
in this state so we'll have to wait and
see guys
yeah wait and see indeed if the strains
are already here aisha thank you
julie